[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président du
sénat mme se prémunissent une président
de l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
président du conseil économique social
environnemental mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames messieurs les
parlementaires dames et messieurs les
élus
mesdames messieurs en vos grades et
qualités je suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui parce que vous
venez de le rappeler par vos propos ce
dont nous allons parler c'est au fond de
la vie quotidienne des français et de
leur avenir n'est pas d'autre chose et
en vérité on choisit le terme de
territoire faute de mieux les français
parlent assez peu de territoire c'est un
mot dont nous nous parlons mais les
français parlent leur campagne de leurs
montagnes de leurs forêts de la maire de
leur ville de leur village leur plein de
leurs banlieues de la diversité qui fait
leur quotidien et c'est au fond le coeur
du sujet qui nous est ainsi posée nous
sommes dans un pays qui s'est construit
par la norme par la langue par l'état
par l'impôt il faut bien le dire aussi
son administration et dont les grands
vecteurs en quelque sorte d'homogénéité
ont été imposées d'en haut
or notre pays et fait de géographie
multiples nous restons éminemment un
pays de terroir et de géographes est
dans une mondialisation qui tente à tout
homogénéiser l'attachement de nos
concitoyens alors quotidien à la réalité
de leur territoire est encore plus grand
de chaque jour et le défi qui est le
nôtre n'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais il
est chaque jour un peu plus fort c'est
de conjuguer l'unité de la république
qui nous a fait cette mondialisation qui
parfois bouscule des grands équilibres
et dans laquelle nous avons à avancer et
la diversité de ses territoires qui est
constitutif de nos identités et de notre
identité profonde
et c'est tout le défi qui est le nôtre
parce que cette pluralité de situation
nos concitoyens là vivent dans leur
quotidien ils n'ont pas le même
quotidien selon qu'ils habitent
territoire très rural une banlieue
métropolitaine une ville moyenne de
province où qu'il soit dans un
territoire ultramarin ou une zone de
montagne nous le savons bien
et les tentations des extrêmes que vous
avez révoqué sont alimentés par le
sentiment chaque jour documenté il faut
bien le dire que notre approche est
monolithique unilatérale univoque et au
principe d'égalité sur lequel notre
république s'est construite nous devons
bien aujourd'hui considérés en quelque
sorte une forme d' attention toute
particulière à une égalité des chances
des territoires car l'égalité qui créent
de l'uniformité n'assure plus l'égalité
des chances sur la totalité de notre
territoire aujourd'hui c'est cette
sensibilité qui nourrit les inquiétudes
les incertitudes que je sais nombreuses
que cette conférence nationale des
territoires et c'est mon souhait profond
que notre action collective dans les
prochaines années doit permettre de
résoudre cette sensibilité territoriales
c'est justement cette faculté d'écouté
les millions de voix qui chaque jour
s'expriment partout en métropole et en
outre-mer cette démocratie vivante et
exigeante qui tissent ce commun
je veux rendre ici un hommage aux
fonctionnaires de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales ainsi qu'aux
acteurs locaux sans qui rien ne serait
possible
à ce titre et je veux aussi remercier
tout particulièrement
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre propos
liminaire les élus locaux
parce qu'ils ont pour une très large
majorité d'entre eux une activité quasi
bénévole et pour la totalité d'entre eux
décidé de consacrer une partie
significative de leur vie à l'intérêt
général
sans compter leurs heures quand il
s'agit d'écouter d'agir de retisser ce
lien en prenant des risques
et là dessus vous l'avez rappelé je
souhaite en effet que nous puissions
faire aboutir cette réflexion déjà
commencé sur le statut de l'élu local et
en particulier les critères de
responsabilité pour pouvoir répondre à
ce qui fait aujourd'hui le quotidien de
saison si nous sommes ensemble
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas pour ajuster
une nouvelle fois les lois de
décentralisation aux réalités
contemporaines ou pour chercher à
expliquer aux français en quelque sorte
que leur vie devrait se plier à nos
organisations administratives et
institutionnelles
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on raisonne
ainsi je crois d'ailleurs que nos
concitoyens ne voit plus le bout
nous mêmes nous sommes confrontés à
l'insatisfaction en quelque sorte de ce
travail de sens sans fin en tout cas à
portée de vue et à ce titre la
philosophie qui sous-tend ces
conférences nationales des territoires
c'est bien plutôt de refonder le rôle de
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales dans la vie quotidienne
des françaises et des français et
d'adapter ce rôle aux transitions que
notre pays doit affronter et pour ce
faire il faut repenser en profondeur
l'interaction entre l'état et lesdites
collectivités nous connaissons
parfaitement les analyses et nous les
partageons mais ce que nous installons
aujourd'hui avec cette conférence c'est
une instance des changes de concertation
et de décision
cette conférence elle se réunira tous
les six mois sous la présidence du
premier ministre
elle est composée de membres du
gouvernement de représentants des
collectivités territoriales des
présidents des organismes de
concertation existants et de
représentants du parlement
elle se saisira d'un certain nombre de
thèmes transversaux ou territoriaux qui
seront traités dans la durée elle ne
doit en aucun cas conduire à
recentraliser des sujets qui relèvent du
dialogue quotidien entre les
représentants de l'état et les
collectivités dans les territoires mais
de ces négociations
émergera un pacte de confiance entre
l'état et les territoires des finissants
pour les cinq prochaines années les
engagements respectifs que nous devons
prendre au coeur de ce projet je place
notre volonté que chaque réforme
chaque plan chaque démarche initiée par
le gouvernement pour mettre en oeuvre
des politiques publiques dont la
responsabilité est partagée entre l'état
et les territoires associés en amont les
collectivités territoriales concernées
et cette conférence pour toutes ces
raisons monsieur le président du sénat
ne pouvait pour sa première réunion se
tenir ailleurs qu'ici au sénat qui au
titre même de l'article 24 de notre
constitution que vous avez rappelé
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
république
c'était mon souhait je vous remercie de
l'avoir acceptée et de nous avoir
parfaitement accueilli la volonté de
mettre en place cette conférence tient à
une réalité simple qui structurent à mon
propos nous avons des transitions
inédite à vivre elle impose de repenser
en profondeur le rôle de l'état elle
impose de reconsidérer la méthode entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
elle conduit immanquablement à repenser
aussi la méthode et les réalités de nos
relations financières
notre temps c'est en effet celui des
transitions c'est ce défi qui est au
coeur de toutes les politiques publiques
que nous avons à conduire la relation
des français avec le travail l'école
l'environnement la famille la mobilité
les loisirs est en train de changer
profondément et cela sous l'effet de
l'évolution des mentalités des savoirs
des comportements et des technologies et
donc nous ne pouvons pas garder les
organisations les réflexes parfois le
rythme qui était celui d'un monde qui
précédait ces changements nous ferions
une erreur de diagnostic historique si
nous pensions que ces transitions sont
d'ailleurs les mêmes partout et pour
tous au contraire elle adopte selon le
lieu la géographie les tranches d'âge
des dynamiques territoriales et sociales
qui sont profondément différente et dans
les conséquences
sont profondément différente mais pour
chacune de ces transitions nous devons
penser cette égalité des chances que
j'évoquerai et sortir des cadres de
pensée qui ont parfois été les nôtres ce
que demande la ruralité
ça n'est pas l'aumône ça n'est pas
d'être compensée c'est d'avoir les mêmes
chances de réussir c'est d'avoir les
mêmes chances de réussir que d'autres
territoires de la république
là où ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
parce qu'elles n'ont plus les
infrastructures essentielles de la
réussite dans ce monde en changement et
la réalité des services publics utiles
dans leur quotidien les défis sont ainsi
profondément différent selon les
territoires
mais avec des exigences qui sont
communes à tous ces territoires
cette égalité des chances territoriales
et les transitions que nous sommes en
train de vivre ont cela de
caractéristiques qu'elles sont en train
d'accroître l'individualisation et la
différenciation par territoire qu'il
s'agisse du numérique de la transition
environnementale
elle renforce cette tendance qui sont
déjà à l'oeuvre prenez la transition
énergétique elle renforce la production
locale
la déconcentration profonde
désorganisation là où nous étions
organisés aujourd'hui dans un modèle
très étatique avec une production
hypercentralisé prenait la transition
numérique
elle donne la capacité à reproduire sur
le terrain de manière beaucoup très
différenciée elle permet de redéployer
des perspectives de travail sur le
territoire de télétravail mais aussi de
télétravail 2.0 qui va complètement
changer les phénomènes de congestion
si on va au bout des équipements
nécessaires de la capacité à faire de
l'impression 3d où toutes les tous les
modes de production a dit yves est
justement de permettre à tous les
territoires de relever ces défis
l'industrie du futur émergent dans tous
vos territoires brisant d'ailleurs la
distinction qui s'était faite entre eux
l'industrie et les services
c'est fini ce temps où des territoires
entiers en quelque sorte été condamné à
se construire
dans un avenir de service là où les
industries des avait déserté c'est faux
le numérique est en train de retisser
des liens entre justement l'industrie et
les services de permettre à nouveau des
productions industrielles au plus près
du terrain
si on s'en donne les moyens tout ça pour
dire que les repères dans lesquelles
nous avons construit jusqu'à lors
l'action publique ont profondément
changé et nous conduisent à repenser en
profondeur les défis de nos territoires
mais en même temps ils ont très
profondément accrue aussi la disparité
de situations et de conditions de départ
je ne serai pas exhaustif mais on le
voit bien les défis sont profondément
différents selon les types de
territoires les territoires ruraux
enclavé de plaine comme de montagne ont
un défi d'accès aux infrastructures
essentielles qu'il s'agisse des
infrastructures routières ou
ferroviaires comme des infrastructures
du numérique et ont à se battre face à
la désertification des services publics
nos littoraux et nos montagnes
connaissent des conflits d'usagé
croissant entre des potentialités de
développement économique
les souhaits de certains acteurs
touristiques ou économique et le souhait
de leurs habitants et les mêmes parfois
d'ailleurs qu'il dise qu'il souhaite un
avenir radieux pour leurs territoires
sont les premiers à s'opposer à certains
projets quand leurs habitants y voient
au réel de leur quotidien
ledit conflits d'usagé les territoires
touchés par les transformations
économiques et les chocs liés à la
mondialisation des 20 dernières années
ont un relevé le défi de l'affaissement
de notre empreinte industrielle et avec
elle de l'accumulation des difficultés
économiques et sociales et ont un besoin
d'états dead de redistribution bien
différent d'autres régions de la
république les villes moyennes ont quant
à elles à inventer un nouveau modèle de
croissance
or des métropoles s'appuyant sur les
avantages sectorielle à un niveau
qu'elles peuvent établir mais aussi à
construire des éléments en réseau avec
d'autres villes moyennes où justement
par une politique culturelle économique
éducatif 10
quand elle construirons une attractivité
renouveler les métropoles enfin ne sont
évidemment pas à l'écart de ces grandes
transitions elles ont elles sont même en
leur coeur elles sont aujourd'hui à
beaucoup d'égards
les gagnants de cette mondialisation qui
favorise les faits de centralité et de
métropolisation mais elles ont à gérer
des problèmes essentiels de pollution de
congestion des espaces qui impose là
aussi de travailler sur des
investissements nouveaux l'organisation
de la ville de demain
et comment ne pas évoquer les
territoires d'outre-mer qui sont
confrontées souvent au cumul de nombre
de difficultés que je viens d'évoquer
mais avec une extrême diversité car sous
ce dénominateur commun ou en quelque
sorte on les enferme fréquemment
qu'y at il de commun entre mayotte et la
guyane la guadeloupe et la réunion
un éloignement peut-être par rapport à
l'hexagone mais des réalités économiques
industrielles de tension géographique et
parfois migratoire profondément
différent entre ces dix territoires
c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs conduit à ce
que le gouvernement organise des assises
de l'outre-mer à l'automne qui
permettront de poser un diagnostic
partagé et une feuille de route
territoire par territoire pour conduire
à des actions concrètes
vous l'avez compris à travers cette
diversité de situation je veux
manifester ainsi que ces grandes
transitions que nous avons à vivre
impose à l'état non plus de garantir
l'égalité parfaite elle est impossible
l'uniformité rêver elle peut se
transformer en cauchemar
mais bien plutôt de tenir son rôle est
d'assurer une égalité des possibles et
des chances et de permettre à chacun des
territoires compte tenu de ses
contraintes de départ de réussir les
transitions qui sont à l'oeuvre et font
le monde contemporain dans lequel nous
avons évolué c'est pourquoi l'état doit
lui-même réinventer son rôle face à
cette transition
l'état doit désormais agir de façon
différenciée en tenant compte justement
de ces réalités territoriales et
autrement dit c'est de se tenir aussi
près qu'il est possible des besoins et
des attentes locales de ne pas craindre
de donner plus à ceux qui ont moins de
redessiner des libertés concrètes dont
nous avons besoin c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi dès les premiers mois de mon
mandat j'ai souhaité que nous puissions
avec pragmatisme revisité plusieurs
politiques publiques afin d'y injecter
davantage de liberté pour les
territoires en laissant aux
collectivités locales la liberté de
définir les rythmes scolaires pertinent
dans leur territoire et en investissant
dans l'école avec le dédoublement des
classes de cp et ce1 en zone ray
paieraient plus réforme qui se déploiera
pour une large partie dès cette rentrée
c'est une politique de différenciation
territoriales et les acteurs locaux en
ont la responsabilité
c'est avec le même esprit que l'état
investira davantage dans les transports
du quotidien afin de permettre aux
français
enclavée de retrouver la mobilité
physique sans laquelle il n'est pas de
mobilité sociale et sur ce point il est
en particulier essentiel de créer le
lien entre les principales
agglomérations et leurs territoires
environnants notamment entre les
métropoles et les territoires ruraux
excentré car c'est là que se construit
la première des fractures territoriales
et non plus en promettant des grands
plans uniforme ou qui consiste à sommet
en quelque sorte
toutes les promesses tenues sur tous les
territoires et qui ne sont jamais
financé mais plutôt pour construire par
une méthode participative ce qui sera un
vrai plan de mobilité pensez au contact
de territoire et qui permettra justement
de répondre aux besoins du quotidien
c'est cette méthode qui a été retenu dès
la fin de l'été
la ministre des transports lancera les
travaux préparatoires à une loi
d'orientation des mobilités qui offrira
une programmation précise année par
année financés sur cinq ans un conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures de
transport instance d'expertisé de
dialogue entre toutes les parties
prenantes
suivra la mise en oeuvre de cette
formation auprès de la ministre des
transports et vous y serez bien entendu
associé
mais cette méthode elle conduit à quoi
avoir un discours de vérité sur les
infrastructures de transport et à
prendre en compte cette diversité des
territoires
il y aura un temps de dialogue on
regardera les besoins et il y aura des
décisions sous la supervision du premier
ministre parce qu'on ne peut pas
promettre des lignes de tgv des
aéroports de proximité à la france
entière
ça peut aujourd'hui me faire à coup sûr
un succès d'estrade
simplement je reviendrai dans quelques
années devant vous et le même succès des
strates se terminera en reproches
légitimes
j'ai peur au demeurant qu'on l'ait
beaucoup fait et donc ce qui sera décidé
au terme de cette concertation
c'est une loi qui associera à chaque
projet son financement
c'est avec le même état d'esprit enfin
que je me suis engagé à la couverture
intégrale pour tous les français en très
haut débit
je souhaite encore accélérer ce
calendrier afin de parvenir à une
couverture en haut et très haut débit
d'ici la fin de l'année 2001 sur ce
sujet avec nombre d'entre vous durant la
mandature précédente
nous avons construit des solutions pour
essayer de couvrir les manques de
rattraper les retards de pousser les
opérateurs
c'est la première chose qui nourrit les
extrêmes
la première chose je dis fin 2020 je
vous confirme plus 2022 vous n'êtes vous
avez bien entendu parce que si je vous
dis 2022 je ne suis pas sûr que je serai
en situation parfaite de pouvoir en
répondre si je vous dis fin 2020 je sais
que j'aurai encore l'année 2021 pour
pouvoir rattraper les retards
[Applaudissements]
mais parce que nous avons appris
collectivement avec le temps d'abord on
a promis de couvrir les centres bourgs
rapidement on s'est aperçu que la
couverture du centre bourg ne valait pas
couverture de la commune grâce
d'ailleurs en particulier au sénat je
m'en souviens les amendements ont été
pris qui ont permis de déployer des
antennes relais des antennes relais et
donc de conduire les opérateurs à avoir
des contraintes supplémentaires
est ce encore suffisant pas totalement
les déploiements ne sont pas assez
rapides
les opérateurs aujourd'hui rechignant
corps dans les endroits qui sont les
moins rentables
nous devons donc d'ici à la fin de
l'année prendre des dispositions
nouvelles d'incitation et de contrainte
à l'égard des opérateurs de téléphonie
ensuite ont ensuite regardé également la
nature du plan qui a été pensée par
l'état pour envisager les
complémentarités technologiques
il est impossible de tenir la promesse
de tirer de la fibre dans tous les
logements de la république
ça n'est pas vrai cette promesse est
intenable technologiquement et
financièrement par contre nous devons et
nous pouvons jouer sur les
complémentarités entre la fibre et le
mobile et en particulier l'internet
mobile nous pouvons déployer des
cellules dites cellule femto et nous
pouvons jouer sur la complémentarité
avec le déploiement satellite qui est
docteur d'ailleurs de la stratégie de
l'état en la matière
c'est donc aussi s'être plus cette
reconfiguration technologique qui doit
être portée enfin l'état affectera une
part du grand plan d'investissement à
cette priorité pour là où c'est
nécessaire
là où des carences seront constatés se
substituer aux opérateurs des fire agir
de façon différenciée
c'est aussi se concentrer sur certaines
priorités par territoire ainsi nous
veillerons à ce que l'évolution des
services publics en milieu rural ne
conduisent pas à augmenter la fracture
territoriale
j'ai notamment demandé à ce que
l'enseignement primaire en milieu rural
soit rendu plus attractif par exemple en
amplifiant des expérimentations locales
très prometteuse autour d'internât et
c'est ce que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale aura à présenter dans les
prochains mois nous devons faire plus
pour l'égalité d'accès au savoir et à
l'excellence de même je me suis engagé
et nous le ferons a doublé le nombre de
maisons de santé dans les territoires
ruraux pour garantir l'accès aux soins
et nous travaillerons là à la mise en
place d'une stratégie territoriale
d'accès aux soins permettant de garantir
une accessibilité renforcée par des
moyens novateurs
je pense notamment au déploiement de la
télémédecine dans la ministre des
solidarités de la santé sera tout
particulièrement en charge de ce projet
en même temps que les réformes
structurelles mais qui prendront du
temps seront prises pour rouvrir les
numerus clausus qui ont construit on le
sait bien
cette rareté aujourd'hui du personnel
médical sur les territoires en matière
d'école et de santé je ne souhaite pas
qu'on revienne en arrière ou qu'on
reconstruit ce qui a parfois été
détricoté je souhaite aller à la fois
vers plus d'innovation et proposer une
évaluation partagée des besoins cette
évaluation doit être conduite d'ici à la
fin de l'année afin de construire un
plan d'action conjoint entre l'état et
les territoires ce qui est sûr c'est que
les territoires en particulier les plus
ruraux ne peuvent plus être la variable
d'ajustement d'économies c'est pourquoi
d'ici là en particulier il n'y aura plus
de fermetures de classes dans les écoles
primaires
en matière d'environnement
les collectivités sont aussi des
partenaires incontournables de la mise
en oeuvre du plan climat récemment
annoncées et notre objectif sera de
déployer dans les prochains mois tous
les territoires à énergie positive dans
une logique partenariale avec l'ensemble
des territoires qui les portent
pour l'état vous l'avez compris dans ce
contexte que je viens de décrire
le premier enjeu est la lutte contre la
fracture territoriale l'état et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
travailler de concert afin de construire
cette cohésion des territoires monsieur
le ministre de favoriser leur
complémentarité est d'organiser les
solidarités les régions départements
métropole communes doivent prendre toute
leur part dans la construction de cette
alliance entre territoires pour
favoriser leur meilleure complémentarité
et c'est parce que je suis conscient de
certains défis de la situation de
déclassement des villes moyennes et de
la ruralité que je veux justement que
nous puissions nous inspirer de ce qui a
été fait en d'autres temps de manière
forte à propos pour les villes avec
l'anru cette idée a été porté par
d'autres que moi particulier dans les
temps récent de campagne et je pense que
c'est une bonne idée de considérer
l'opportunité d'une agence nationale de
la cohésion des territoires
cette agence
[Applaudissements]
cette agence elle aura vocation à
travailler en lien direct avec les
régions parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de
recentraliser ce qui a été donné à
certaines collectivités et donc ça doit
être une agence là aussi d'un type
nouveau qui travaille en lien direct
avec les régions qui pensent l'appui en
particulier en ingénierie publique
indispensable dans le rural et dans les
territoires les plus périphériques et
qui crée une logique de guichet unique
et de simplification de projets pour les
territoires ruraux les villes moyennes
en difficulté cette agence alors à
vocation à simplifier pour l'ensemble de
celles et ceux élus aux porteurs de
projets sur le territoire qui veulent
conduire à bien ses projets et qui se
trouve confronté aujourd'hui à notre
propre complexité administratif à la
multiplication des clichés parfois il
faut bien le dire à nos propres
incohérences
je souhaite donc en lien direct avec
vous et sous l'autorité du premier
ministre
une réflexion très précis soit conduite
pour que cette agence voit le jour qui
permettra de répondre de manière très
efficace est en lien direct avec le
ministre de la cohésion territoriale et
sous son autorité à ces défis nous avons
besoin d'une logique d'âge ans parce que
c'est une logique de projet que porte
aujourd'hui cette france rurale cette
france des villes moyennes qui veut
réussir et pour qui la lenteur et la
complexité est presque encore plus
insoutenable que pour les grandes villes
et les métropoles pour les villes
moyennes
la priorité est de redonner vie au
centre-ville je souhaite à ce titre que
le gouvernement engage une action
renforcée et transversale pour relancer
l'emploi
le commerce le logement et remettre des
centres villes au coeur de leur
territoire pour cela il faut instituer
une politique globale d'intervention en
lien avec la région
les financements dont l'état dispose
sont aujourd'hui propriété ont fait
l'objet on le sait bien de coupe
successives ils doivent être largement
délégué aux régions et l'état doit venir
en appui à ces dernières pour là aussi
avoir une approche beaucoup plus globale
de l'ensemble des outils
qui sont mises à disposition qu'il
s'agisse des quartiers prioritaires des
villes moyennes
le panel d'outils pour répondre à leurs
difficultés en matière d'éducation
d'emploi de commerce de transport de
numérique de culture doit être simplifié
regroupés il sera demandé au préfet de
nommer à leurs côtés des personnalités
locales entrepreneurs dirigeants
associatifs responsables culturels
fonctionnaires capable d'entraîner ce
mouvement en lien direct avec les élus
locaux
cette mobilisation des acteurs locaux en
appui des élus autour de projets
concrets et l'apport par l'état des
outils nécessaires à l'émancipation de
ses territoires donnera lieu à une
contractualisation sur une durée
minimale de cinq ans enfin dans les
métropoles
l'état soutiendra les projets
d'innovation et de recherche dans le
développement est indispensable à
l'économie et au rayonnement de la
france il sera en appui en particulier
de tous les projets de transition
numérique et environnemental
aujourd'hui porté par les métropoles et
sur lesquelles l'état sera
particulièrement présent à travers le
grand plan d'investissements c'est aussi
en matière de transport et de logement
bien évidemment dans les métropoles que
l'état à repenser sa politique
je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure pour ce
qui est des transports avec une volonté
de concentrer nos financements sur les
infrastructures du quotidien ce qui
signifie les travaux de rénovation
indispensable dans toutes les métropoles
où les investissements n'ont pas été
conduits depuis plusieurs années
conduisant des problèmes qui de
congestion urbaine qui parfois
d'insécurité pour les usagers pour ce
qui est du logement
là aussi c'est une réponses
différenciées que nous devons apporter
nous le savons bien
les politiques qui consiste à inciter à
la construction de logements partout sur
le territoire avec des outils fiscaux
extrêmement cher ne fonctionne plus
l'état français est l'un de ceux qui
dépensent le plus en matière de logement
simplement comme bien souvent nous avons
une politique de subvention de la
demande pas une politique d'offres nous
dépensons 2 point de produit intérieur
brut sur les politiques de logement pour
assumer quoi accompagner l'augmentation
des prix
et solvabiliser les ménages qui sinon
n'auraient pas accès à ces politiques
le coeur du problème il est on le sait
dans deux trois zones métropolitaines en
france le grand paris lyon et la
frontière suisse et la métropole
aix marseille principalement où les prix
ont beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
années sur ces territoires nous devons
faciliter fortement la création de
logements nouveaux
accompagner les métropoles qui
conduisent ces politiques libérez nos
territoires nos terrains beaucoup plus
rapidement que nous l'avons fait sans
chercher à faire des plus values et
mettre en place une limitation des
procédures de recours et de tous les
délais qui sont autant de coûts
supplémentaires c'est pourquoi à
l'automne un projet de loi sera porté
par le gouvernement qui permettra dans
toutes ses zones tendues de créer un
choc d'offre qui permettra je l'espère
en deux trois ans c'est en tout cas
l'objectif qui doit être le nôtre de
baisser fortement le coût du logement
dans ces territoires
nous renforcerons également je m'y étais
engagé les crédits de l'anru pour aider
les quartiers les plus en difficulté sur
ce point permettez moi un mot tout
particulier sur le grand paris je ne
veux pas ici exposés des conclusions
hâtives
le verrez chacune et chacun nous avons
commencé ce travail avec le premier
ministre
et dès cet automne après une
concertation approfondie avec les
acteurs concernés
je proposerai les bases du grand paris
qui aujourd'hui je dois vous le dire de
manière honnête est au milieu du gué en
raison d'une structuration trop complexe
l'idée du grand paris mérite mieux que
ce que nous en avons collectivement fait
il faut bien le dire
de part et d'autre pour des raisons
politiques et pour déséquilibre
incertain mais si nous voulons que le
grand paris réussissent à l'échelle de
ce qu'est la compétition internationale
si nous voulons produire la richesse
pour ensuite pouvoir la répartir
harmonieusement sur le territoire nous
avons besoin de simplifier drastiquement
les structures et je réunirai à ce titre
une conférence territoriale du grand
paris qui devra se refonder autour d'un
projet ambitieux de développement de la
première métropole française au sein de
la région capitale et aboutir à une
organisation institutionnelle stabiliser
et efficace
enfin pour ce qui est du rôle de l'état
vous l'avez évoqué je souhaite que nous
renforcions la déconcentration et que
nous donnions représentants locaux de
l'état plus de marge de manoeuvre
notamment en matière budgétaire et de
ressources humaines mais aussi dans le
dialogue quotidien avec les
collectivités territoriales pour adapter
les politiques de l'état aux besoins des
territoires et à ceux de nos concitoyens
ce sera la responsabilité du premier
ministre dans les prochains mois de
porter ce projet mais il est fondamental
vous avez parlé de l'inflation
législative à juste titre mais nous en
sommes les coproducteurs pourquoi j'ai
dans une vie antérieure était ministre
combien d'entre vous font passer aux
ministres du gouvernement tel ou tel mot
de manière totalement justifiée et à bon
escient
parce qu'un problème local n'est pas
réglée par le préfet et on porte un
amendement législatif pour régler le
problème dans tel département parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre voie que d'aller
la régler avec le ministre créant ainsi
six mois plus tard le même problème mais
à l'envers
dans le département voisin qui
conduiront à un amendement à peu près
symétrique
revenant sur le premier d'un autre élu
tout aussi bien inspiré cette
chorégraphie qui conduit à un
balbutiement certains ne la connaissons
par coeur
parce que nous avons progressivement
déposséder les fonctionnaires de terrain
du pouvoir légitime qui doit être le
l'autre le leur parce que nous avons
déposséder les préfets les services sur
le terrain de ce pouvoir d'appréciation
de dialogue avec les élus locaux
et quand on ne modifie pas la norme ce
sont alors des délais combien en
instruisant un dossier que vous leur
avez donné ou dire je le remonte à paris
ça va prendre six mois
je veux que nous sortions de cette
fascination de la politique de la
circulaire pour avoir une politique de
la stratégie au niveau central
quand les stratégies sont claires elles
n'ont pas besoin de regarder le moindre
tour de vis dans chaque département
notre pays
et ensuite
il doit y avoir un contrôle a posteriori
légitime capacité d'appel nos
administrations centrales doivent vivre
un peu cette réforme et cette
transformation profonde
il ya trop de fonctionnaires des
circulaires et pas assez de
fonctionnaires qui aident sur le terrain
est donc cette déconcentration sera
conduite les préfets pourront ainsi en
particulier ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui indépendamment de cette
déconcentration disposer d'un pouvoir
d'adaptation locale des règlements en
particulier à l'issue du projet de loi
simplification et droit à l'erreur qui
sera présenté dans les prochaines
semaines par le gouvernement
tout cela l'état peut et doit le faire
et c'est pourquoi il doit consentir à un
changement de paradigme complet mais
au-delà de ce rôle de l'état je crois
profondément que dans la très grande
majorité des cas les territoires en
réalité savent mieux l'organisation qui
est la plus pertinente pour eux il faut
donc construire ce pacte girondins que
j'ai évoqué il ya quelques semaines qui
sans briser l'unité nationale redonnera
aux territoires les moyens d'agir dans
une responsabilité partagée
après des années de réformes nombreuses
et parfois contradictoires je vous
rassure et monsieur le président j'ai
entendu que vous l'appeliez de vos voeux
il ne s'agit pas pour moi de refaire un
grand soir institutionnels nous
perdrions du temps de l'énergie et j'ai
peur qu'en la matière d'ailleurs le
schéma parfait n'existe pas vraiment
cela signifie qu'il n'y aura donc pas de
nouvelle grande réforme des institutions
ou des collectivités des niveaux de
collectivités
mais je suis ouvert aux adaptations
législatives qui permettront de corriger
les éléments d' aberration qui remontent
du terrain sur l'eau je vous ai entendu
sur les transports scolaires j'ai cru
entendre certains d'entre vous sur tous
ces sujets nous procéderons de manière
pragmatique aux adaptations nécessaires
par contre je souhaite que nous
puissions
à partir de logique de terrain procédé à
des réorganisations nécessaires la
réforme conduite a permis de clarifier
les niveaux de compétences
c'est un fait elle a recomposé des
territoires et une cartographie que vous
connaissez parfaitement mais elle n'est
pas allée au bout des éléments de
simplification qui sont pourtant
nécessaire si nous voulons avoir une
action publique plus rapide et moins
coûteuse là encore je souhaite que nous
puissions ensemble simplifier les choses
l'état prendra ses responsabilités en
rationalisant les services et les
agences des concentrés pour accroître
l'efficacité de son action et je
souhaite que l'ensemble des
collectivités puissent faire de même là
où des collectivités territoriales le
souhaiteront et si les regroupements
sont conformes à l'intérêt général
nous les accompagnerons n'imposeront pas
mais nous offrirons des libertés je
pense notamment à la création si c'est
souhaité de communes nouvelles au
regroupement qui sont portés par les
collectivités au volonté de
rapprochement de certains départements
s'ils sont souhaitées par ces derniers
avec cette conviction c'est que quand la
logique est porté par les territoires et
qu'elle correspond à la simplification
de l'organisation territoriale aux
dynamiques de bassin de vie d'emploi ou
bassin économique elle est pertinente
mais cette liberté d'organisation ne
doit pas se traduire par une
augmentation des fractures territoriales
et elle ne doit pas se traduire non plus
par une augmentation de notre propre
complexité c'est pourquoi sur ce sujet
j'aurai des lignes rouges simple si on
accroît les inégalités les déséquilibres
en proposant les rapprochements entre
des territoires qui constituerait un
îlot de richesse dans des régions des
bassins de vie qui sont déjà
profondément déséquilibré
ça n'est pas une bonne chose pour
l'intérêt général
si on considère que le sens de
l'histoire c'est alors qu'on a créé des
grands région de rouvrir des maisons
départementales de la région
j'ai peur que nous n'avions pas vers des
économies pertinente et donc sur ces
points là j'en appellerai au pragmatisme
collectif et les tares regardera avec
beaucoup d'attention
tous ceux qui ne viendra pas accroître
les inégalités et les déséquilibres et
tout ce qui ne viendra pas rajouter de
la multiplication des structures et des
redondances
partout les grandes régions voudront
contractualiser avec des départements ou
des métropoles pour partager des conques
des compétences au plus près du terrain
s'il leur semble pertinent d'être au
plus près du terrain nous les aiderons
nous les accompagnerons partout ils
recréeront des structures
administratives pour se déployer
elle-même en concurrence avec d'autres
territoires
il ne me semble que nous créerions
immanquablement ensemble de nouveaux
vous l'avez compris je souhaite
accompagner encourager les initiatives
supprimer les verrous encore trop
nombreux qui contraignent les
territoires dans leur souhait de
s'organiser mieux en vue d'une action
publique plus efficace
cette liberté elle sera laissée aux élus
locaux en lien avec les représentants de
l'état
aussi pour expérimenter de nouvelles
politiques publiques de nouvelle
organisation des services publics mais
aussi pour innover en matière
d'aménagement du territoire d'urbanisme
et pour définir notre territoire de
demain le droit à l'expérimentation à ce
titre sera simplifiée nous lèverons
notamment l'actuel obligation d'une
généralisation de ces expérimentations
sur tout le territoire au bout de deux
années qui est un verrou terrible pour
permettre celle ci et la différenciation
de l'action publique dans les
territoires doit être désormais acceptée
parce que c'est le prix de cette égalité
des chances et si c'est nécessaire
sur ce sujet je suis prêt à proposer
dans le cadre de ce que j'ai annoncé au
congrès une révision de la constitution
pour faciliter ces évolutions et libérer
les énergies
je suis je suis également disposé à ce
que l'état délègue en tant que de besoin
ses compétences en matière économique
sociale ou d'aménagement si l'intérêt
locale le justifie
je souhaite notamment que le
gouvernement poursuivre le partenariat
privilégié engagé avec les régions en
en matière de développement économique
et d'emploi et je suis prêt dans ce
cadre à envisager de nouvelles
délégations de compétence
ou des transferts de structures aux
régions qui le souhaitent cette
délégation pourra s'accompagner aussi
d'un transfert du pouvoir réglementaire
d'adaptation des normes juridiques aux
réalités locales
vous l'avez évoqué je pense que c'est
une évolution que nous devons suivre
regardez et accompagner si elle est
souhaitée à ce titre les collectivités
d'outre-mer ont ouvert la voie à ces
réflexions du fait même de leur statut
constitutionnel spécifiques
je sais que certaines d'entre elles pour
ce qui est des collectivités
ultramarines souhaite revoir les
amendements constitutionnels passé que
nous connaissons parfaitement
j'y suis parfaitement disposés et au
delà je souhaite que nous puissions
envisager également en métropole dans le
respect du principe d'égalité
de telles adaptations je demande au
gouvernement aussi d'expertisé avec vous
tous les moyens pour simplifier et
moderniser la gestion de la fonction
publique territoriale dans le dialogue
indispensable avec les syndicats de
fonctionnaires afin de mieux répondre à
leurs besoins qui sont différents de
ceux de l'état et avec une volonté
simple avoir une fonction publique
territoriale qui nous permette
collectivement de relever les défis que
je suis en train d'évoquer il n'est pas
normal lorsqu'on cherche à augmenter
par exemple le point de la fonction
publique hospitalière que toutes les
fonctions publiques soit entraînée dans
le même mouvement
nous devons avoir une gestion
différenciée des fonctions publiques
parce que leur réalité est différente
parce que les contraintes de gestion
qu'on fait ensuite pesé de manière
mécanique sur les collectivités locales
sont insoutenables
[Applaudissements]
il faudra également que toutes nos
responsabilités soient prises en la
matière je connais par coeur la
chorégraphie de dupes qui existe entre
nous sur ce sujet
quelqu'un doit prendre la responsabilité
de dire la vérité
la cour des comptes l'a dit les heures
travaillées ne sont pas totalement en
conformité avec ce qui est prévu pour
l'ensemble de la fonction publique où ce
qui est le cadre privé nous de vous
mettre fin à cette situation parce que
c'est insupportable pour nos concitoyens
qui ne sont pas fonctionnaires publics
territoriaux et parce qu'on ne rend pas
service à la fonction publique
territoriale en protégeant des
archaïsmes
je vous le dis en toute franchise
il faudra également j'en ai la
conviction engagé une réduction du
nombre d'élus locaux comme j'ai indiqué
souhaiter le faire poser les élus
parlementaires
nos concitoyens ne comprendraient pas
sinon un tel traitement différencié
moins d'élus mais des élus plus protégés
mieux rémunéré et plus libres de leurs
actions enfin l'état doit se garder
vous l'avez dit c'est le président du
sénat de l'inflation des normes alors je
prends acte de votre avertissement
initial et je ne me risquerai pas à la
promesse du moratoire
puisque vous l'avez dit vous-même 7 en
quelque sorte en la matière les hôtes
ont team aurum enos
c'est celui qui a le couteau qui est en
même temps la plaie est une sorte on ne
sortons jamais de ce jeu infernal par
contre je suis favorable à ce que nous
puissions conduire en effet une revue
générale des normes
je suis favorable à ce que nous
puissions appliquées et que le
gouvernement s'en charge
le principe du deux pour un pour toute
nouvelle norme pesant sur les
collectivités territoriales
deux autres devront être supprimés et je
souhaite à ce titre que nous renforcions
le rôle du conseil national d'évaluation
des normes qui doit être associée
beaucoup plus en amont à l'analyse des
lois et des décrets concernant les
collectivités territoriales c c'est sur
ce sujet le premier ministre à ses côtés
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
qui sera chargé de s'assurer que tous
les textes sont soumis à ce tamis je
demande par ailleurs au gouvernement que
l'on mette un terme aux transferts de
compétences sournois je pense par
exemple transfert de la responsabilité
de la délivrance des titres d'identité
aux communes
aux surcoûts liés à l'application de
normes environnementales ou
d'accessibilité qui n'étant pas pris en
compte initialement ne font l'objet
d'aucune compensation
le législateur doit prendre en compte à
chaque fois qu'il établit une norme
obligatoire
son impact administratifs et financiers
sur les collectivités territoriales est
l'une des finalités de ces conférence
semestrielle sera de rétablir la
transparence et la confiance sur ce
sujet pour que l'analyse des coûts
induits puisse être observés mesure est
constaté et retranscrit dans nos
relations financières
je souhaite enfin que nous ne sur
transposition pas les normes européennes
et que nous visions chaque fois qu'une
norme européenne est claire et précise à
son application directe à cet égard que
nous puissions examiné systématiquement
dans les régions transfrontalières en
particulier les normes en vigueur chez
nos voisins européens afin d'évaluer
l'efficacité de nos propres normes et la
nature des applications vous l'avez
compris la liberté que j'entends
redonner aux territoires celle de
s'organiser de fonctionner elle est
inséparable de la confiance mutuelle que
nous devons nous faire et elle repose
aussi sur une responsabilité partagée
qu'impose la situation financière du
pays
et c'est là dessus que je souhaite
terminer mon propos sur cette
responsabilité financière partager tout
ce que je viens d'évoquer ce sont des
libertés nouvelles qui vous seront
donnés une capacité à vous organiser
différemment à trouver des latitudes et
donc aussi des organisations des
économies plus intelligente mais disons
les choses là aussi en vérité nous
partageons la même responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
comme de nos concitoyens celle de la
soutenabilité de nos finances publiques
il en va ainsi de la part
gouvernementale sociale et locale de
cette dépense or nous le savons le
niveau de nos dépenses publiques est
trop élevé le niveau de prélèvements
obligatoires l'est tout autant
et donc nous devons procéder à une
double désintoxication
à cet titre cela n'empêche pas de
préparer l'avenir
c'est pourquoi la stratégie que le
premier ministre a exposé il y a
quelques semaines d'économies
substantielles en matière de
fonctionnement s'accompagnera aussi d'un
plan d'investissement qui permettra sur
les priorités d'investir et en
particulier avec des milliards d'euros
du grand plan d'investissement que nous
lancerons à l'automne qui seront
consacrés au soutien à vos projets et
avec aussi la volonté de mobiliser
davantage les crédits de la banque
européenne d'investissement dans le
cadre des projets portés par les
territoires mais nous avons besoin de
partager cette contrainte alors qu'elle
était le premier ministre a évoqué ce
matin
l'état doit faire des économies
substantielles pour baisser durant ce
quinquennat de trois points de produit
intérieur brut la dépense publique c'est
l'engagement pris nous serions encore au
dessus de la moyenne de la zone euro
mais c'est un engagement qui me semblent
soutenable et qui en tout cas est celui
qui nous permet de retrouver de la
souveraineté financière ce qui compte
tenu justement de nos pas réciproque
conduirait les collectivités
territoriales a participé à la baisse du
déficit des administrations publiques à
hauteur de 13 milliards d'euros sur le
quinquennat
c'est plus élevé que ce que nous avions
anticipé parce que la situation trouvée
était plus dégradée ce que nous pensions
mais c'est une part qui est qui
correspond c'est une part qui correspond
à la part des collectivités
territoriales dans l'ensemble de la
dépense publique pour permettre cette
amélioration du solde des
administrations publiques
nous ne procéderons pas par baisse
brutale de dotation je m'y étais engagé
mais c'est un pari que nous faisons
ensemble et comme disait le philosophe
levinas la confiance c'est le problème
de l'autre
moi je vous fais confiance la logique
budgétaire c'est de couper les dotations
en 2018 nous ne le ferons pas mais avec
un pari c'est que les collectivités
locales nous toutes leurs composantes
seront prendre pour 2018 la part de ce
qui leur revient en baisse de dépenses
de fonctionnement et d'investissement
bien comprise sans que nous ayons à
passer par les dotations considérant que
la dotation c'est justement ce qui donne
de la visibilité ce qui permet
d'accompagner les changements
intelligent ce qui permet d'avoir de la
visibilité de l'efficacité mais ça
suppose que utilisant tous les leviers
que je viens d'évoquer de suppression de
niveau inutile de collectivités de
flexibilité nouvelle en terme
réglementaire en termes de fonctions
publiques territoriale vous puissiez
produire des économies intelligentes à
ventre main mais moi je veux sortir de
ce jeu de dupes qui nous unit dans une
espèce de tango infernale qui n'omettra
il mènera ensemble sinistre par contre
celles et ceux qui ne joueront pas le
jeu il y aura un mécanisme de correction
de l'année d'après je vous le dis tout
de suite parce que sinon c'est un jeu
qui favorise le passager clandestin
mais je crois à la logique de confiance
je crois donc à la capacité que nous
avons à procéder à cette économie
intelligente
alors ensuite je ne mésestime pas les
points importants et structurants de la
dépense publique qui sont aujourd'hui
devenues insoutenables et crée des
déséquilibres profonds
le premier le financement des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur les
départements de manière inégale et mais
certains en situation de forte tension
financière
je pense notamment au financement du rsa
qui atteint aujourd'hui ses limites
il ya une alternative sur ce sujet qui
s'offrent à nous soit une
recentralisation du financement avec
justement la reprise en main par l'état
soit une amélioration de la compensation
avec tout un débat que vous avez déjà eu
par le passé sur l'année de référence
mais avec un manque ablement aussi le
renforcement de la péréquation
horizontale
je souhaite que ce sujet dans le cadre
de ses conférences soit débattue
ma préférence je vous le dit tout de go
il irait plutôt à la première option
pourquoi parce que je considère que le
rsa doit relever d'un continuum des
politiques d'emploi quitte ensuite à
conventionner avec des régions qui
souhaiteraient avoir cette politique
d'emploi et je pense que sortir le rsa
de la cohérence des politiques d'emploi
n'est pas la logique dans laquelle nous
inscrivons plus largement mais je
souhaite que vous ayez ce débat à plein
et que vos travaux puissent trancher
d'ici le printemps prochain pour que le
plf 2010 9 reflète les décisions prises
d'ici là les situations d'urgence pour
certains départements seront bien
évidemment prise en compte par le
gouvernement
deuxième point sur ce sujet des finances
locales
c'est évidemment vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le président du sénat la taxe
d'habitation
là aussi disons nous les choses
la taxe d'habitation est elle un bon
impôt non c'est un impôt qui ne regarde
pas les capacités contributives des
citoyens pas parce qu'il est local ou
pas locale il est comme ça il ne regarde
pas la capacité contributive nos
citoyens il est donc injuste socialement
plus que tous les autres et il est
injuste territorialement parce qu'il se
trouve qu'il est plus élevé dans les
villes périphériques ou les centres
bourgs de province que dans les grandes
villes c'est la vérité qui peut ainsi
mesurer je vous invite à tous le
constater donc il accroît l'injustice
sociale et territoriale que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
donc ce n'est pas un bon impôt et ça
c'est pas parce qu'il est territorial on
va pas se mettre à faire en quelque
sorte camp contre camp sur les impôts
là il ya une chose qui devrait nous
rassembler c'est chercher quand même
aller baissé collectivement en faisant
de la dépense plus intelligente
par contre donc cet impôt n'est pas bon
ensuite j'entends votre argument qui
consiste à le dire c'est bon d'avoir un
impôt qui reste en contact avec le
citoyen oui on fait une mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous ça fait bien des
années que cet impôt pour une part non
négligeable de notre population ce lien
n'existe plus c'est aussi la vérité qui
d'ailleurs accroît la visibilité pour
les communes les plus en difficulté qui
concentrent les difficultés et les
populations les plus pauvres qui a un
faibli ce lien donc maladie au carré si
je puis dire
alors j'entends la promesse de revoir
les valeurs locatives cadastrales
j'ai peur que certains les déjà essayé
pour être honnête avec vous j'ai cru
comprendre que cette réforme était porté
depuis une quarantaine d'années quand
même peut-être certains d'entre vous
dans cette salle s'était essayé à la
voter avait commencé à faire des
simulations et s'était aperçu qu'il y
avait un tiers des communes qui est
perdez et avait donc préféré ne pas
l'appliquer c'est la vérité donc je vous
propose qu'on gagne collectivement du
temps en essayant pas de refaire des
batailles qui ont déjà été conduites
déjà perdu et qui objectivement ne
permet pas de répondre aux défis de nos
concitoyens donc à court terme
dès la rentrée prochaine il y aura en
tranches successives une suppression
pour 80% comme je me suis engagé de la
taxe d'habitation pour nos concitoyens
sur trois ans avec un mécanisme
d'exonération qui permet la compensation
financière pour les collectivités sans
leur faire perdre la liberté de taux ce
sera fait progressivement ses
conférences permettront d'ailleurs de
partager l'information financière
tous les six mois et de bien s'assurer
que les évolutions dans cette période de
la base et donc les habitants nouveau
que vous auriez sont bien compensé dans
ladite évolution puisque je suis
conscient de vos craintes légitimes sur
le sujet instruit par le passé mon
souhait c'est que nous allions plus loin
parce que oui un impôt qui serait in
fine est payé par 20% de la population
c'est pas un bon impôt mais je ne serai
pas en quelque sorte comme on l'a fait
depuis des décennies
renvoyée à nos concitoyens la charge de
la preuve se noue la renvoie nous donc
en même temps que nous ferons ça et ce
dès maintenant je souhaite que nous
ouvrions dans le cadre d'une commission
de travail qui doit vous associez et pas
être une commission simplement
administrative une réflexion profonde de
la refonte de la fiscalité locale et en
particulier en substitution de la taxe
d'habitation avec des principes simples
qu'on puisse arriver au même résultat
financier in fine et qu'on maintienne
l'autonomie fiscale tout
particulièrement des communes qu'on
garde le lien pour justement la vertu
civique que vous évoquiez entre les
habitants et la commune et que donc on
réfléchisse éventuellement à une part
d'impôts nationale qui pourrait être
attribuée aux communes par
csg ou de cerner ce qui est un impôt au
moins proportionnelle qui est plus
intelligente que ne l'est aujourd'hui
l'actuelle taxe d'habitation
mais prenons le temps de reposer cette
refonte de la fiscalité locale
donnons nous jusqu'au printemps prochain
dans le cadre de cette commission pour
mener cet exercice en profondeur qui est
indispensable mais je souhaite d'une
part contiennent l'engagement pris parce
qu'il est nécessaire en termes de
pouvoir d'achat et de justice
territoriale et je souhaite que nous
menions cette refonte en profondeur de
la fiscalité locale qui l'est tout
autant
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
souhaitais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas exhaustif
mais j'ai déjà été long parce que le
sujet est vaste et la tâche qui nous
attend est vaste
vous l'avez compris c'est pourquoi je
souhaitais en ce début de mandat venir
avec le premier ministre plusieurs
membres éminents du gouvernement vous
exposer ses vues cette volonté de
méthode
je crois dans la confiance on a trop
essayé la défiance dans le pays et on a
vu que ça ne marchait pas
donc nous ne prenons pas grand risque je
crois dans l'ambition des réformes
profondes que nous devons porter je veux
les porter pour l'état à travers ce à
quoi je me suis engagé j'attends de vous
que vous les portiers pour les
collectivités c'est essentiel ceux qui
pensent que le statu quo les protégerait
se trompent
croyez moi ils ne les protégera pas des
changements qui de toute façon
adviendront et ne protégera pas
davantage de la colère parce que les
gens sont lucides je crois au respect au
respect partagé la transparence que nous
mettrons entre nous permettra de
l'assuré à chaque instant mais je
souhaite vous l'avez compris que à
travers cette confiance cette
responsabilité partagée entre nous nous
puissions relever ensemble les défis
chacun des défis que vous portez c'est
un bout du mien je ne me défoncerai
jamais sur vous en disant c'est
peut-être est-elle comme une telle m
c'est un jeu les gens n'y croient plus
c'est la même chose
nous sommes tous et toutes dans la même
galère pour nos concitoyens nous
réussissons ou pas et donc vos problèmes
ce sont les miens à chaque instant mais
croyait bien que mes problèmes ce sont
un peu des vôtres aussi
je voudrais que vous en soyez convaincus
et donc pour toutes ces raisons pour
réussir ces transitions nos ambitions
peuvent être considérables c'est
pourquoi je souhaite
mesdames messieurs que nous ferions
collectivement à hauteur du porte du
projet que nous portons et que je
souhaite que ces conférences nationales
des territoires puissent nous permettre
de réussir ce pari de la confiance de
l'efficacité du respect pour que notre
action commune qui est l'action publique
ainsi partagé permettent au pays de
réussir permettre de donner aux français
ce qu'ils méritent
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
pour cette allocution du président de la
république
emmanuel macron devant les représentants
des collectivités locales
le président qui va maintenant quitter
la salle après avoir salué les ministres
présents pour cette première conférence
nationale des territoires on va
évidemment revenir sur ce discours
j'accueille sur le plateau pour